welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and stranger things season four
final two episodes are coming to life
first and if only i could i'd make a do
with god to know how this season ends
because i love volume one so much and i
have so many questions about the final
two episodes a new promo dropped during
the nba finals game so let's break down
the new stuff from that and talk about
some unresolved mysteries from this
season i know you're terribly frightened
by what you've seen
my friends need me
you're not ready
[Applause]
there is nothing you can do
your friends
have lost
so some of this new footage was shown in
the volume 2 promo or in the first seven
episodes but along with the new stuff is
a shot of murray with a flamethrower
nancy facing the vector and upside down
because let's not forget she's still
down there or up there or over there or
in there but then this interesting new
shot of will crying as he hugs jonathan
now there are a few ways to read this
one being that someone might have died
maybe joyce hopefully not we need to
protect winona at all costs but this
could also be the moment that will comes
out to jonathan i have more thoughts on
how this moment could actually be a huge
victory for all of the characters then
there's a shot of lucas taking a swing
at basketball team captain jason thank
god it looks like this is in the attic
at the creel house now remember there
was a shot in the previous promo showing
lucas screaming in fear as the shadow of
a floating figure hovers over him and
then part of this scene there's a shot
in the trailer of someone in navy
colored socks floating off the ground
before i thought this could be max being
taken by the vecta again but max wore
white color socks in these episodes and
now i think it is jason as avecna's next
victim now jason is all kinds of
problematic and one issue i had with vol
1 is the way it depicted the bullies
jason and hawkins angela and lenora
hills as sadistically cruel without
reason now i get it high school is hell
and sometimes kids are just evil but
stranger things as a series has always
defied that 80s movie trope by making
apparent stereotypical bullies like
steve harrington redemptive figures with
empathetic motivations so i think for
jason at least we will learn what past
trauma is motivating this satanic panic
witch hunting and his hatred of eddie
munson and unfortunately for eddie now
if jason does end up dead that's not
going to help eddie's legal trouble that
much though who knows maybe lucas knows
jason's favorite song and saving him
from the vector could be finally what
converts jason to go easy on eddie as we
saw in the promo from two weeks ago the
adults in russia will discover some lab
where the soviets are experimenting on
things they get from the upside down
including what looks like a piece of the
misty flesh of the mind player what are
they doing with it how did they capture
part of it and what will be learned
about the mayan player again something
i'll talk about the end of the video it
looks as though jonathan mike and will
will make it to the desert missile silo
where brenner owens and eleven are
remember this is in ruth nevada maybe
it's just coincidence but running up
that hill is such a major anthem for the
season and it's worth noting that when
you abbreviate running up that hill you
get r-u-t-h or ruth and yes there is
that shot of nancy facing down the
vector volume one ended with nancy still
stuck in the upside down but she cannot
die this way they're gonna have to play
her favorite song to get her out of
there and i love the idea that the shots
from the trailer earlier this year of
eddie munson shredding on his guitar
atop that trailer in the upside down
could be him playing nancy's favorite
song robin might know nancy's favorite
song as when they were in her bedroom in
episode four robin definitely rifled
through nancy's cassette tapes so what
is nancy's favorite song some are
suggesting the nod nancy's tom cruise
poster could suggest her favorite song
might be something from top gun like any
logins danger zone or berlin's take my
breath away but but but both of those
songs came out with top guns released in
may 1986 which is a few months after
this season is set that tom cruise
poster is not a top gun poster the fact
that robin called attention to it was
really a callback to season one when
steve saw it and said people say he
looks like tom cruise which ended up
being a running bit with steve dressing
up like tom cruise and risky business in
the season two halloween party in season
one steve and nancy had their first kiss
to totos africa so it might be africa
because let's face it we are all
shipping nancy and steve but also those
two later hooked up to foreigners
waiting for a girl like you but if nancy
associates that memory with losing barb
i don't know if that would be her
favorite song i mean who knows maybe
it's the theme from the neverending
story
now for me the biggest question
remaining for this season is the vechna
clock imagery the grandfather clock
appearing to each of the vectors
impending victims definitely a menacing
way of showing one's time is almost up
but i am convinced there is something
deeper to this i love the speculation
around the school guidance counselor ms
kelly because when max visited her in
her home to get her off its keys miss
kelly wears a necklace of a key with a
clock on it and the grandfather clock
that keeps appearing to all these people
from the creel house has a keyhole on
the left side and more than one of the
vectors victims are kids that ms kelly
spoke to uh
i don't know about that might just be a
red herring but still clocks in time are
obviously important to stranger things
in the opening flashbacks of the season
the shot that showed the crack on the
wall of the hawkins lab teasing the fact
that eleven open that first riff to the
upside down to banish one and transform
him to the becna the clock in that shot
shows the glare from the ceiling light
over the numbers 11 and 1. a clue that
what led to this was a conflict between
11 and 1. i mean even in episode 7 every
shot where you see the clock behind one
the numbers 11 and 1 are always
connected by that light glare and you
remember the first episode also includes
11 saying this interesting line about
the way time passes emotions can make it
speed up or slow down we are all time
travelers if you think about it time
travelers we know that's got to come
back in some way now does your daily
grooming routine involve a signature
scent if not maybe you just haven't
found the right one a great way to up
your scent game is to try said bird
scentbird is reimagining everything
about how people discover shop for
purchase and even experience fragrances
every month you get to pick the designer
fragrances you want to receive so there
are no surprises they have perfumes and
colognes as well as a lot of unisex
options with each fragrance you'll get a
30-day supply so you can try out
fragrances before committing to an
expensive full-size bottle that can cost
you hundreds of dollars you can discover
new fragrances by taking a simple quiz
on scentbird to help you find the
fragrance that you'll love send bird
carries luxury brands prada gucci
versace and niche brands like skylar
heretic and confessions of a rebel this
month my box included book by commodity
as well as well played by confessions of
a rebel i really liked well played by
confessions of rebel for it's fresh
lavender tonka bee notes incense coca
seed it's just got this nice dare i say
sexy center plus i've always considered
myself something of a rebel or at least
i i have aspired to be and i get so many
of them to try look at all this and now
i got enough to wear it all month long i
got sprays for days and really these
aren't these dinky sample size amounts
there's a lot in this bottle it's got
some weight to it i'm gonna be able to
make this last there's so much cologne
in both of these so be sure to use our
coupon code for 55 percent off at
cenford it's just a little over seven
dollars for your first month it's an
amazing deal available in the usa and in
canada especially since in episode seven
one rants about time as an artificial
societal construct where others saw
order i saw a straitjacket a cruel
oppressive
world dictated by made-up rules seconds
minutes hours days weeks months years
decades each life a faded lesser copy of
the one before i could not pretend and i
realized i didn't have to
[Music]
now we don't know exactly what the
rewinding of the clock meant because
it's not like one or vector mentioned
anything about rewinding time at that
point in the monologue perhaps he was
just moving the hands of the clock
telekinetically as a symbolic protest of
society's rules but
i think time travel will actually happen
in some form on this series the
grandfather clock i think is a nod to
the grandfather paradox the thought
experiment that ponders if it would be
possible to go back in time and kill
one's own grandfather as that would
erase one's own existence theoretically
disproving the possibility of time
travel unless you adopt one of the any
other forms of time travel theoretically
possible including what we saw in
avengers endgame that going back in time
causes alternate timelines to branch off
from the timeline creating a multiverse
of possibilities and alternate
dimensions which is interesting because
nancy realized that the upside down was
actually frozen on november 6 1983 the
night will went missing that suggests
that the upside down is specific to will
buyers now it makes sense for the upside
down to be something from will's mind
otherwise the parallels of its monsters
to dungeons and dragons are just super
coincidental like even if they're just
the kids using dnd to label these things
they do line up pretty perfectly to how
d d characters function maybe the upside
down is a dimension where will buyers
spent countless years in solitude
something that's felt like thousands or
millions of years as dustin hypothesized
this season but in actuality time does
not exist in this dimension it's a
pocket dimension that spawned with will
buyers existing on a plane independent
of time now back in season two we
learned that there was a connection
between will buyers and the mind flayer
but i have been on the fence when it
comes to the theory that will byers is
himself the mind player or the mind
player is like will in the future just
because it triggers me back to our game
of thrones theories that bran was the
night king and many have rightly pointed
out that if slash win they reveal will
to be gay on this series it would just
kind of suck if you were also the big
bad of the series and i agree with all
of that however we may be missing a
possibility here that the mind player is
not the will buyers that we have gotten
to know over these four seasons that
will is still and always will be one of
the heroes of the story but perhaps the
mind player could be will buyers that we
do not know as well a darkest timeline
version of him who never escaped the
upside down who lost all of his friends
and never accepted himself and that
alternate timeline will is who evolved
into the mind player in this time
independent realm that is why i think if
the hug shot is will coming out it would
be such a triumph this will the will who
has grown up with us who we've been
following on this series is our hero he
is the one whom the darkest timeline
version of will is trying to erase in
this way the message wouldn't be
something as awful as being gay makes
you evil no not at all but rather a
suggestion of a nightmare that many have
gone through that a version of yourself
that is so overwhelmed with shame that
shame is the evil so the ultimate
challenge is to accept yourself and you
will kill that shame i mean i don't know
is that still problematic i just want it
to be okay for will to be gay but also
to be the source of all the cool stuff
on this show is that too much to ask
again i cannot wait for the final two
episodes to prove me right or probably
prove me wrong and thanks again to
scentbird for their sponsorship of this
video and be sure to check out all their
links below follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to nerox stars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you